من المعروف أن الجبال الجليدية تشكل أخطارًا على
السفن ، ولكن يوجد الآن خطر كبير قبالة
جرينلاند يهدد بالفعل عالم
الأرصاد الجوية في القرية بأكملها ، إريك فان
دان ، انضم إلينا الآن وهو يتتبع
هذا ليس فقط أي جبل جليدي قديم ، وهو جبل جليدي يبلغ وزنه 11
مليون طن ، أي 11 ميغا
طنًا ضخمًا.  ولدينا بعض
الفيديوهات الرائعة لتظهر لك كيف يبدو هذا
الجبل الجليدي الذي يبلغ وزنه 11 مليون طن
متوقفًا بشكل غير مستقر بالقرب من
هذه القرية الصغيرة الواقعة قبالة غرب
جرينلاند ولكن هناك مخاوف من قبل
بعض السكان المحليين
وهو جبل الجليد الذي يولد
اندلعت التي شاهدتها في الفيديو هناك ،
سنقوم بعمل هذا
المقطع الدعائي ، هذا الفيديو أريد أن أعرضه
لك فقط لأنك انظر إلى تلك الموجة الصغيرة التي
بدأت في الصعود إلى تلك القناة الصغيرة الصغيرة ،
حسنًا ، هذا تسونامي صغير
كان معروفًا بحدوث
ما  نحن قلقون حيال ذلك هو أن
هذا الجبل الجليدي ومزيج من
الطقس الدافئ والأمطار الغزيرة قد يتسببان في تساقط
قطعة أكبر من الجليد من
الجبل الجليدي مما يخلق  تسونامي أكبر ،
لذلك قام السكان هناك على طول
الساحل بإجلاء
حوالي 170 ساكنًا في جميع أنحاء تلك المنطقة
وجيدًا لسبب وجيه للنظر في
هذا في جبل الجليد هو حجم
الملعب تقريبًا أو يمكن أن يكون ، لكن هذا فقط
الجزء الذي أنا وأنت  ترى أنه حقًا
شكل الجبل الجليدي فوق السطح ،
تذكر أن غالبية الجبل الجليدي يقع في
الواقع تحت سطح المحيط ، لذا فإن
حوالي 80 إلى 90 بالمائة منه
غير مرئي للعين البشرية ، لذا فإن
الوضع المثالي لهذا الجبل الجليدي قبالة
ساحل  سيكون غرب جرينلاند من أجل
أن تنشغل بما يسمى
الحمام والتيارات ، فسوف تضيع في
الحمام والخليج والأزمة على اليمين ، ولكن
إذا تسببت الظروف هناك في
هطول أمطار غزيرة وذوبان
جيد لهذا الجبل الجليدي الكبير الذي يبلغ مرة أخرى
10  حتى 11 ميغا طن يمكن أن تكسر
قطعة كبيرة من الجليد وتتسبب في حدوث ذلك التسونامي الصغير